تطورا لافت في العاصمه السودانيه وبين
مكانه الخرطوم تشهد اشتباكات متقطعه قامت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعمليه اجلاء
نوعيه لرعاياها من مقر السفاره الامريكيه
في ضحيه سوبا جنوب الخرطوم وذلك بمشاركه
ست طائرات امريكيه هبطت في مبنى السفاره
وكانت قياده الدعم السريع السودانيه اصدرت
بيانا اوضحت فيه ان قواتها نسقت القوات
الامريكيه المكونه من ست طائرات بغرض
اجراء دبلوماسيين واسرهم وان قوات الدعم
السريع قامت بالاشراف على الترتيبات
اللازمه التي سبقت عمليه الاجلاء
ورئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اكد عمليه
الاجلاء التي قال ان الجيش الامريكي نفذها
باوامر منه واشار بايدن الى ان الجيش
الامريكي نجح في اجلاء الامريكيين الى بر
الامان متوجها بالشكر للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وجيبوتي واثيوبيا حيث وصف بايدن
دور هذه الدول بالحاسم في نجاح عمليه
الاجلاء ودع الرئيس الامريكي لطراف
المتحاربه لتنفيذ وقف فوريا وغير مشروط
لاطلاق النار وسماح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه دون عوائق واحترام اراده شعب
السودان
من جهاته قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال
ان بلاده علقت بصفه مؤقته العمليات في
سفاراتها بالخرطوم بسبب تزايد المخاطر
الامنيه واجلت جميع الموظفين الامريكيين
وعائلاتهم بامان اضافا الاداره الامريكيه
ستواصل مساعده الامريكيين في السودان في
التخطيط للسلامتهم مكررا دعوه لطرفي
الصراع لتمديد هدنه العيد وتوسيع نطاقها
على نحو عاجل من اجل وقف دائما للاعمال
القتاليه
بدوره وجه وزير الدفاع الامريكي انه
بتوجيه من الرئيس بايدن نفذ الجيش
الامريكي والقوات الامريكيه عمليه اجراء
للموظفين الامريكيين في الخرطوم ووجه
اوستن شكر للسعوديه وجيبوتي واثيوبيا على
ما وصفه بالجهود الحاسمه في اجراء
الموظفين
معسكر ليموني رسميا هو القاعده العسكريه
الدائمه والوحيده التي تديرها القوات
الامريكيه في افريقيا
جغرافيا هي اقرب قاعده امريكيه في المنطقه
للاحداث في السودان وهي تقع في دوله
جيبوتي
القاعده تضم وحدات من القوات الخاصه
والبحريه والطيران ويصل عدد القوات فيها
الى اربعه الاف جندي في الاوقات العاديه
تستغل لحمايه الملاحه البحريه في باب
المندب وفي استهداف الجماعات الارهابيه في
القرن الافريقي اضافه الى تدريب الجنود
التابعين لدول افريقيه مختلفه
معسكر لمونى يحتوي على مطار عسكري قد يكون
هو المحور الاساسيه في اي عمليه اخلاء
محتمله للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
انس نماسي العربيه
طبعا نشير معكم الى هذه المعلومات
المتفرقه من عددنا المسؤولين الامريكيين
حول حيثيات عمليات الاجلاء الاخيره التي
كنا تحدثنا عنها اولا عدد الاشخاص الذين
تم اجلائهم هو اقل من 100 شخص وقد تم
اجلاء عدد من الدبلوماسيين من دول اخرى في
العمليه العسكريه الامريكيه التي استمرت
ساعه واحده على الاراضي السودانيه ولم
تتعرض لاي مشاكل للمعلومات ايضا انه لم
يعد هناك اي مسؤول امريكي على الاراضي
السودانيه في المقابل مازال هناك عدد كبير
من الموظفين المحليين لاداره شؤون السفاره
الامريكيه البارز ايضا هو تصريح من مسؤول
في الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي قال ان واشنطن
لا تتوقع اي تغيير في الوضع الامني الحالي
في السودان على المدى القريب
ونذهب معكم الى الخرطوم ينضم الينا من
هناك رئيس تحرير صحيفه الجريده اشرف عبد
العزيز سيد اشرف اهلا بكم معنا في هذه
التغطيه المستمره على شاشه العربيه الوقت
مازال مبكرا الان في الخرطوم ولكن كل
الاعين على العاصمه السودانيه هل من
تفاصيل حتى هذه الساعه اذا ما استجد اي
جديد
يعني اليوم هو في هنالك هدوء نسبي ولكن لا
زالت هنالك يعني بعد الاجر الناريه تسمع
بين الفين والاخرى في المناطق الملتهبه
اصلا وهي المنطقه التي في وسط الخرطوم في
محيط القياده العامه والقصر الجمهوري
بالاضافه الى بعض المناطق المتوزعه في
الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري
سيد اشرف اليوم نحن امام هذه الهدنه التي
من المفترض ان تنتهي في غضون الساعات
المقبله ما هي التوقعات وفق المعطيات على
الارض
بعد هذه اله
دنه هي مفلى انما زالت الرغبه هي وما زالت
الرغبه هي موجوده بضروره الرغبه موجوده
لدى كل طرف بانه لابد ان يقضي على الاخر
ويعلن انه حضر النصر الساحق والماحق ففي
تقديري الايام القادمه ستشهد مزيد من
المواجهات المكثفه في اطار حسم المعرفه
خاصه معرفه كسر العظمى في منطقه وسط
الخرطوم طيب استاذ اشرف هل هذه المعطيات
تشي فعلا بان هناك تصعيدا قادما في الايام
والساعات المقبله خصوصا اذا ممر اليوم
التاسع نحن في اليوم التاسع اليوم الاحداث
السودان
هنالك تح مستمر وهنالك طلعات جويه مستمره
ايضا من قبل القوات المسلحه فهذا يعني ان
هنالك مواجهه محتمله في القريب العاجل هي
مؤجله فقط بسبب الهدنه وبالتاكيد ستكون
هنالكم مواجهات على اوسع نطاق فيما يتعلق
بالسيطره على هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر
استراتيجيه بالنسبه للطرفين طيب في هذه
الحاله استاذ اشرف هل من مبادره سياسيه
بانه فشل للاتفاق الايطالي
نعم هنالك الكثير من المبادرات يعني هي
افضل
المبادرات التي بدات
[موسيقى]
لا للحرب لابد ايضا في الخرطوم من ان تكون
هذه الجبهه التي يدعو لها كثير من الزعماء
والنشاطات السودانيين ان تكون هي جبهه
موحده
جميع السودانيين فيما يتعلق بوقت هذه
الحرب باعتبار انه بعد اجلال رعايه
الاجانب نحن نتذكر محادثه في رواندا بعد
نجلاء الرعايه الاجانب وذلك يعني كانت هي
بدايه الجزر الحقيقيه للحرب الاهليه
الواسعه النطاق لابد ان المسؤوليه اصبحت
الان هي رفيعه واثقل بالنسبه للقوه
المدنيه في الخرطوم لكي تتحرك بشكل اكبر
ولو تعرض نفسها للخطر في سبيل الوصول الى
اكبر فيما يتعلق بوقت اطلاق النار
فقط لكي نفهم من كلامك يعني هل تتوقعون
اليوم بعد انتهاء عمليات الاجلاء خصوصا
اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب ان تجتد حده
المعارك يعني اليوم وكان السودانيون
سينفردون بين بعضهم البعض في القتال
هذا واضح يعني لان يعني غياب الفساد
الدبلوماسيه يعني ان هنالك فشله بماقد
يعني فيما يتعلق بالاتصال بين
الاطراف المتسارعه وهي هذه الفحوصات وان
هذه الفساد لن تستطيع انتشار هدنه اكبر
فيما يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار وبالتالي هي
وكانها تعلن ان الاوضاع اصبحت الان الوضع
اصبحت غير امنه وكون الاوضاع غير امنه
فهذا يعني انهم مرشحه لمزيد من التصعيد
وطول امت هذه الحرب وهنا نخشى في ان
تتواصل المجال المتعلقه بتبادل الاطلاق
النار والاشتباكات على مدى نطاق واسع طيب
استاذ اشرف ارجو ان تبقى معنا في سياق هذه
التغطيه نذهب معكم الى هذه الصور الان
نتابع معكم هذه الصور التي وصلتنا الان
اذا نتابع معكم حمتي في اول ظهور له ولكن
نريد ان نشاهد هذا هذه الصور هذه قوات
الان من الدعم السريع في مشهد يبدو انه
امام القصر الجمهوري وفيما يقال بان المده
الفيديو تقريبا مدتها حوالي دقيقه ونصف
ويظهر فيه حميتي خصوصا بعد ثواني يعني اذا
ما تبعتم بعد ثواني سنشاهد مع بعضنا البعض
قائد قوات الدعم السريع حميدتين نتابع
معكم اذا هذه الصور والفيديوهات التي
وصلتنا الان
[موسيقى]
اذن نتابع معكم هذه الصور وما زالت هناك
المعلومات متضاربه بين طرفي الصراع في
السودان حيث تقول قوات الدعم السريع وتؤكد
في اكثر من مره عن سيطرتها لعدد من
المناطق والمنشات الحيويه والعسكريه فيما
الجيش السوداني ينفي ذلك في هذه السياره
اذا هذا هو حمتي ونتابع معكم هذه الصور
التي نعرضها الان مباشره على الشاشه
العربيه طبعا هذا فيديو وصلنا الان ونعرضه
لكم الان مباشره وكانت صور تم تداولها
وكنا نشرناها ايضا في ساعات سابقه على
شاشه العربيه طبعا حميتي كان ظهر في
مقابله يوم امس على شاشه العربيه كان واضح
في كلامه بانه لا يريد الحديث عن تفاوض
الان لكنه قد يتحدث عن هدنه ولكنه اشترت
استسلام البرهان وعصابته كما وصفه فيما
يقول بانه طبعا هذه السياره التي نتابعها
وهذا هو حمتي الان هذه الصور التي نعرضها
لكم فيما كانت دائما هناك تساؤلات اين هو
حمتي واين هو البرهان خصوصا منذ الساعات
الاولى والايام الاولى منذ بدات
الاحتجاجات وبعد ان بدات واشتدت حده
الاشتباكات بين طرفي النزاع كانت هناك
تساؤلات اين هما الان حيث اكد كل منهما
يقول البرهان بانه لم يخرج من مقر القياده
العامه ولكنه لن يخرج منه الا اذا نعش عله
نعش وهذا دليل على انه مستعد ان يقاتل حتى
النهايه فيما ايضا حميدتي يؤكد بانه موجود
في الخرطوم وستساؤلات اين هما بعد هذه
المشاهد التصعيد الاخيره وطبعا كان هناك
تساؤلات حول سياج عالي من السريه يضرب حول
اماكن وجود رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وايضا قائد
قوات الدعم محمد حمدان دقله طبعا كما
المعروف بحمدتي اللذين كما تقول المصادر
وفق اينما الصور والفيديوهات التي عرضناها
بانهما لم يظهر ميدانيا منذ بدء
الاشتباكات اذا ما تحدثنا منذ يوم السبت
الماضي باستثناء سماع صوتيهما بالتاكيد من
خلال التصريحات التي قاما بالادلاء بها
سواء عبر الهاتف من خلال المقابلات
التلفزيونيه في الايام الاولى منذ ذراع
الحرب وايضا حتى اليوم الاخير على شاشه
العربيه مقابله مع البرهان وايضا مقابله
مع السلطه الطبيعي
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر ابشر الله اكبر ابشر
الله اكبر
اذا كانت هذه المشاهد وهذه هي الفيديوهات
التي عرضناها لظهور الاول لقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف في
حمتي منذ ان بدات الاشتباكات في السودان
في مشهد يبدو انها امام القصر الجمهوري
اذا حمدتي كما كنا تبعنا في هذا الفيديو
قبل ثوان بانه يظهر في ثوان داخل عربه
عسكريه وسط جنود او قوات الدعم السريع في
انه امام القصر الجمهوري وسط كل التساؤلات
حول غياب الرجلين اين هما هذه التساؤلات
منذ ان بدات الاشتباكات والصاعدت خلال
الايام الماضيه هذه الاشتباكات اندلعت منذ
يوم السبت الماضي السودان اليوم منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل ليس كما هو كل شيء
تغير بعد ان وصلت الامور للحديث عن
مفاوضات توقيع الاتفاق الاطاري الذي كان
ان ينقل السودان بالمرحله
بالمضي قدما في مرحله ما بعد 2019 بعد
الثوره التي اسقطت نظام البشير في السودان
الذي حكم السودان لثلاثين عاما كانت
الامور قد تصل الى النفق الاخير حتى يتفق
السودانيون ولكن شاء القدر بان لا يتفق
السودانيون واتفقوا الا يتفقوا حيث اندلعت
مواجهات هذه المواجهات هناك تخوفات بان
تتصاعد وخصوصا ان تصل الى حرب شوارع في
المدن طبعا هناك قلق كبير ورايبه خصوصا
وان الاشتباكات موجوده في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم طبعا في الايام وايضا
الاشهر الاخيره وحتى السنوات مر على
السودان الكثير والكثير من الحروب
والازمات والويلات ولكن هذه الحروب
والازمات كانت موجوده في مناطق بعيده عن
العاصمه السودانيه اليوم هناك تركز
للاشتباكات في العاصمه السودانيه بالتالي
هناك قلق وعين وريبه لماذا هذه الاشتباكات
تصل الى العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم طبعا
نتابع معكم جديد الاخبار والمعلومات حتى
الان مازال الوقت مبكرا يعني تقريبا
الساعه السابعه والربع مساء بتوقيت
العاصمه السودانيه حتى هذه الساعه اذا
نعود الى ضيوف هذه التغطيه ومعنا من
الخرطوم مره اخرى رئيس تحرير صحيفه
الجريده اشرف عبد العزيز اهلا بك سيد اشرف
معنا مره اخرى سيد اشرف هل من تعليق اليوم
على هذه المشاهد وسط التساؤلات من قبل
السودانيين وايضا
المراقبين حول وجود العربه العسكريه
وعلامتها يظهر حمدتي بالصوره هذه المره
وليس بالصوت كما كنا نشاهد عبر المقابلات
التلفزيونيه التي كان يجريها
هل تسمعني
طيب يبدو ان استاذ اشرف لا يسمعنا الان
على كل حال لمستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه
ونذكر ايضا بالجديد الاخبار حول عمليات
الاجلاء وكانت هناك تمت عمليات الاجلاء
يوم امس قامت السعوديه باجلاء مواطنيها
وايضا الرعايه الاجانب والرعايه من الدول
العربيه الشقيقه اليوم ايضا عمليه اجلاء
امريكيه نفتدت باواربر من الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن حيث اعلن بايدن بان عمليه
الاجلاء نجحت ووصلت الى بر الامان وايضا
كان توجه بالشكر الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ووصف ايضا دور السعوديه بالحاسم
في نجاح عمليات الاجلاء نذهب الان الى
ضيفنا من الخرطوم المحل العسكري الفريق
فتح الرحمن محي الدين فريق فتح الرحمن
مرحبا بكم معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه كنا
عرضنا قبل قليل هذا الفيديو لقوات الدعم
السريع وعلى راسها حميتي يبدو انه امام
القصر الجمهوري في اول ظهور على ما يبدو
له منذ ان بدات الاشتباكات واندلعت حدتها
في الخامس عشر من ابريل هل من تعليق حول
هذا الفيديو من وجهه نظر عسكريه الان
انا اعتقد انه يعني هذا الفيديو يوضح فعلا
ان الدعم السريعه لها وجود لازال في وسط
الخرطوم غريب من الغسل الجمهوري ولكن هذا
لا يغير من الواضح شيء يعني الواقع ان
هنالك اعداد كبيره جدا السريع الان خارج
الماركه تماما يعني اكثر من 90% يستطيع ان
نقول الموبات الدعم السريع خارج المعرفه
تماما مرينا هارب او مستسلم للقوات
المسلحه او غتيل فهذا يعني لا يغير من
المشهد شيء وبالتاكيد الامور التمضيه
الانحسار الصحيحه الان هنالك هدنه والجميع
الان يتم يشعر ان الهدنه لها اثر واضح
بهدوء الاوضاع ولكن بالتاكيد عندما تنتهي
ساعه الهدنه هذه
المسلحه على تنظيف ما تبقى من جيوب وهذه
الجيوب للاسف يعني
في الوسط في المنطقه المركزيه متخذ من
المواطنين العبريات بروح بشريه وبالتالي
ممكن تكون هذه معركه مؤجله لكن سيتم تنظيف
اطراف العاصمه من كل العناصر الدعم
السريعه الى ان تنجلي
تنضف كل اطراف العاصمه بعد ذلك سياتي
الحديثه للمناطق المحسنه
المتحف في الدمعه البشريه يعني الفريق فتح
الرحمن يعني كيف يستقيم هذا الامر عندما
نتحدث عن ظهور وبكل ثقه مثلا بهذه الصور
والمشاهد من قلب العاصمه السودانيه وانت
تقول بانهم 90% خارج السيطره يعني كيف
نفهم الامر من وجهه نظر عسكريه عندما يخرج
قائد لقوات دعم السريع قائد لجهه متحاربه
مع اخرى اليوم في السودان
صحيح هو قائد وخرج مع القوه الغريبه منه
المكلفه بحمايته ولكن يعني هذا لا يعني
انه مسيطر يعني هذا قوته بنسبه كبيره جدا
يعني تعرضت الى خسائر ضخمه جدا لا يمكنها
احد فبالتالي انا اعتقد هذا يعني امر
دعائي
الروح المعنويه لما تبقى من عناصر الدعم
السريع ولكن
سوف لن تجدي هذه العمليه نفعا يعني انا لا
اعتقد انه هذا الظهور سيغير من المشهد شيء
يعني
استغل وقت الهدنه
الوقت المبكر القوات المسلحه معظمها منتشر
يعني لانه منطقه وسط الخرطوم الحوار يعني
معركه مؤجله فقط القوات المسلحه الدافع عن
المرافق الحيويه التي تسيطر عليها تسود اي
هجم عليها ولكن يعني لا تقوم بعمل اعدائه
في هذه المنطقه ولكن في كل المناطق
المنتشره فيها المس
لحه العمليه المسلحه تماما شاهدنا ذلك
بالامس في منطقه
فتح الرحمن اليوم اذا ما نفهم الامر من
وجهه نظر عسكريه عندما نتحدث عن جيش وجيش
نظامي دائما هو معروف بانه ربما ذي خبره
من حيث المعارك او الحروب مع الدول يعني
نتحدث عن دبابات طائرات لكن عندما يتعلق
الامر بحرب شوارع حرب مدن الا تكن الغلبه
العسكريه ربما للجماعات المسلحه اكثر
للميليشيات بانها متمرسه ممتهنه لمثل هكذا
نوع من المعارك بين الاطراف
ات المسلحه
من اين وجدت المهنيه هذا عمل القوات
المسلحه اصلا وهي التي علمتهم يقاتلوا في
المدن وبالتالي يعني لا يصعب عليها ان
تغادلهم في المدن ولكن حرب المدن بطبع حرب
طويله العمل يعني لانه المسلحه لن تستخدم
فيها الثقيله يعني تقول حرب طويله الامد
الا تصب بمصلحه الميليشيات اكثر مصلحه
جماعات مسلحه اكثر من جيش نظامي له
حساباته اليوم خصوصا عندما نتحدث عن حرب
مدن والشوارع وفي مدنيين
حرب المدن ان كانت
لديها خطوط انبات صحيح نقول حرب المدن في
صالحه لكن الان ليس لديهم اي خطوه ذات
وبالتالي حرب المدن ليست لصالحهم لانه حرب
المدن ان كان ليس هنالك خط انبات سياتيك
باستعوار للذخائر التي تستهلكها مهما كثره
الذخيره التي تستحملها ستصل الى مرحله
النفاذ وهذا ما يؤشر الى ان هذه العمليات
ما بين انحسار بحسب بسبب عدم توفر
الاستعوا من
الذخائر بالتحديد
طيب فريق فتح عبد الرحمن ينتقل بعض
المعلومات وبعض المصادر بان قوات الدعم
السريع مدعومه باسلحه حديثه ومتطوره ايضا
وحتى ان عددها كان في السابق يعني نتحدث
عن عشرات الالاف اليوم يفوق ال160,000
يعني نتحدث عن قوات دعم السريع
قوات الدعم السريعه
ما تسمع الكلام ده
100 الف
لا تجعلي الارقام الان انا اؤكد لك ان 90%
منها الان خارج المعرفه الان يمكن ان احنا
ان نكون مجابهين بحوالي 10,000 في عناصر
دعم السريع في كل انحاء السودان لكن ليس
اكثر من ذلك وهذه
العجله الاف ليست لديها معسكر واحد يمكن
ان
تلجا اليه باستثناء كما ذكرت لك قبل ذلك
حي المطار والموقع في مدينه الرياض هؤلاء
الموقعين المحصنين
بدروع بشريه بخلاف ذلك ليس لديهم واحد طب
هذه صحيح يعني منتشرون كبير جدا في
الاحياء السكنيه
تحت الاشجار هكذا ولكن هذا لا يتيح لهم
فرصه القتال لمده طويله يعني يغات
له ثلاثه ايام اربعه ايام اسبوع على
الاكشن ولكن ليس اكثر من ذلك فريق فتح
الرحمن ولكن
اقل من الاشتباكات اقل مازال هناك صمود
ربما امام جيش نظامي بالتالي اذا ما
تحدثنا عن الهدنه الهشه ان صحى وصفها التي
من المفترض ان تنتهي خلال الساعات المقبله
هل نتوقع في الساعات المقبله المزيد من
التصعيد او يمكن الحديث عن حسابات اخرى
وليس يعني نفسي ما شاهدناه في يوم امس
غدا يعني ليس هنالك تصعيد ولكن سيتم تنظيف
الاحياء السكنيه من العناصر المنتشره
وسطها في خلال التمشيط البري باستخدام
القوات البريه يتم دفع هذه القوات الى
خارج المناطق السكنيه ومن ثم يصل الى
مناطق طرفيه يسهل فيها التعامل معهم
بالطيران مثلا او باسلحه يعني اكبر حجما
وبالتالي
يتم تطهير المناطق كلها من من وهذه
العمليه بطيئه للعمل تتم الارجل
ولكن فريق فتح الرحمن يعني تقول بانه لن
يكون هناك تصعيد في الساعات المقبله بل
الوضع كما هو اليوم لكن كلام الرجلين
القائدين يوم امس يوحي بانهما مستعدان
للقتال حتى النهايه ويريد ان يلغي كل طرف
منهما الاخر ماذا نفهم من ذلك اذا
غدا مثل اليوم قلت لك غدا مثل امس امس لم
يكن مثل اليوم كان هنالك اشتباكات كان
هنالك تطهير لمنطقه بحري كان هنالك تطهير
لاجزاء من درمان وغدا سيكون
صحيح كل يدعى الى الغاء الاخر وانا يعني
واثق تماما ان المسلحه تقريبا الان رسمت
ظهر الدعم السريعه تفضل مجموعات حول حميتي
وتبقت مجموعات المتحصنه بالدراع البشريه
وتبقت المجموعات الهائمه في الشوارع والتي
تهتمي بالمواطنين في الاحياء السكنيه وهذه
العمليات تستمر لمده ثلاث ايام اربعه ايام
الى
هؤلاء
العناصر من وسط الاحياء السكنيه ويتم
التعامل معهم بعد ذلك بطريقه يعني يعني
القوات المسلحه الان ايديها مكبله بسبب
تواجد هذه لكن
ايضا هي تعرف كيف تستخدم كل سلاح في
المكان المناسب لديها كثير من الاسلحه
لديها كثير من البدائل ولكن
بصبر وحنكه وحكمه لكي لا تدفع الخسائر الى
اعداد يعني غير محتمله هذا فرضته هو الذي
يطير من امد هذه الازمه لكن عموما يعني
نحن الان نشاهد 17 ولايه 17 ولايه بخلاف
ولايه الخرطوم 17 ولايه عادت فيها الحياه
الى طبيعتها تقريبا بنسبه اكثر من 95%
معظم الاحياء خارج
الدوائر التي تتواجد فيها عناصر الدعم
السريعه الحياه فيها الاسواق فتحت
المواصلات تعمل يعني حتى اصحاب الاعمال
اليوميه بداوا يمارسون اعمالهم يعني هذه
اعتقد يعني كلها مؤثرات عافيه
وقناطق الان الموجود فيها عناصر دعم سريع
فرصه بالنسبه لهم الان هذه الهدنه ياخذ
انفاسهم يحاولوا يجمعوا صفوف نوعا ما لكن
اؤكد لك معظمهم والان يفكر في كيف يخرج من
هذه الورطه وكيف يخرج من هذه الاسماء
ونؤكد لك رغم الحديث القائد حميد تي في في
مقابلاتهم ورغم ظهور هذا لكنه الان يعدي
النبي لما ساق اليه قواته الى الوضع
وبالتاكيد لن يكون وضعه غدا وضعه قبل 15
ابريل بالتاكيد
فهذه يعني بالنسبه له قصاره كبيره جدا
لثروه
والنفوز ولسلطه
فتح الرحمن الجهه الاخرى تعتبر بان هذا
الكلام الذي تقوله منافي للحقيقه والواقع
وبان حمضتي خرج وكانه يعبر عن ثقه وحتى
يطالب البرهان بالاستسلام يعني يشترط
الوصول الى هدنه ومن ثم حديث اذا تفاوض
هذا اذا كان في تفاوض وفق قوله ولكن هذه
الهدنه تكون منوطه باستسلام البرهان على
كل حال سنعود الى هذه النقاط معك من حيث
البعد العسكري لهذه المعركه وهو اساس
اليوم ما بين الطرفين بحيث بانه لا صوت
يعلو فوق صوت المعركه ولكن نعود معكم الى
الصور وهذا الفيديو نستمع بالصوت الطبيعي
لاول ظهور لقاده دعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو منذ بدء المواجهات مع الجيش
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
عيشه الابطال الله اكبر
الله اكبر ابشر الله اكبر
اذا مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه والى
ضيوف العربيه الكرام نذهب الان الى
الخرطوم ومعلم هناك الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي يوسف سراج الدين سيد يوسف اهلا
بكم معنا اليوم استاذ يوسف كل الاحزاب
السودانيه تطالب الاطراف المتحاربه بوقت
اطلاق النار ولكن بعد ذلك برايكم
نعم انا اعتقد انه الحرب الان تدخل مرحله
هي الاكثر تعقيدا بعد مرور اسبوع ونحن في
الاسبوع الثاني للحرب الان يمكن التداعيات
بدا تاثير كبير جدا على المواطنين بدات
اثار الحرب لربما هذا
يحدث صحوه لدى قاده الاطراف المتقاتله
فسمعنا من خلال التصريحات التي
قدمها قائد
القوات المسلحه او الدعم السريع في الامس
كان هنالك اغرار بانه تضرر كبير جدا
للمواطنين للبنيه التحتيه كانما ما يقولان
ان الامور بالنسبه لدعم السريع يقول انه
هو سجل اعتذار
للشعب السوداني على حد تعبيره يعني انه
كان مجبره على هذه الحرب بينما قائد
القوات المسلحه تكلم عن انه هذه الحرب
عبثيه يعني اسمائها بذلك
بطبيعه الحال بيحمل اطرار صريح بعدم جدوى
هذه الحرب او تاثيرها لذلك انا اعتقد انه
مثل هذه الامور المحيطه
بالملابسات المعارك الدائره واثارها على
المواطنين سيكون لها تاثير في المقبل
الايام او المرحله المقبله او الساعات
المقبله تحديدا يعني طيب مما لا شك فيه
بانه دائما المواطن هو من يدفع الثمن
واليوم الازمه الانسانيه في السودان اكبر
من اي ازمه اخرى وخصوصا ما سبقها من ازمات
اقتصاديه ومعيشيه وغيرها في السودان حتى
قبل الخامس عشر من ابريل في الايام
الاخيره ولكن يعني توقعات اليوم من قبل
الاحزاب السياسيه في الايام المقبله هل من
سقف زمني هل نتحدث عن حرب طويله الامد
اليوم في السودان هل يمكن احتوائها
انا اعتقد الان الكره في ملعب القوه
السياسيه السودانيه وهي المعنيه بطبيعه
الحال بمالات الامور الان وبعد
مرحله اجلاء الرعايه عدد من الدول
لرعاياهم الخرطوم اللي هو انعكاسات اليه
تاثير واضح جدا باعتبار انه يشيء بانه
الاوضاع لم تعد متتبع وهذا بطبيعه الحال
سيكون له اثاره على الوضع الدبلوماسي
للسودان ولذلك انا اعتقد ان القوه
السياسيه هي سارعت منذ
تفجر هذه الحرب الى محاوله
تقريب الشقه محاوله ايجاد اختراق في
الازمه بدا واضح من خلال التعنت في الايام
الاولى ولكن رويدا رويدا نزلنا نسمع انها
حسب البيانات التي خرجت بها على الاقل
القوس السياسيه الموقعه على الاتفاق
الايطالي بس يعني الاستاذ يوسف تقول بانه
اليوم الكره في ملعب القوه السياسيه ولكن
حتى الاتهامات تطال الاحزاب السياسيه
والقوى السياسيه في السودان بانها اسهمت
نوعا ما في تاجيج الخلافات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع من حيازها للطرف دون اخر في
الايام وحتى في الفتره الاخيره لحين
الوصول الى مشارف توقيع الاتفاق الاطاري
نعم هذا
محاوله ايضا لتمرير اجنده مفادها ان هذه
القوه السياسيه
دفعت بالامور الى هذا الامر وزرع كلام
يجافي المنطق ويجافي الواضح باعتبار ان
القوى السياسيه المدنيه هي المعنيه
بالامور السياسيه وتم الانقلاب على
الحكومه المدنيه التي كان يقودها الدكتور
عبد الله حمدوك وكانت هذه امور معلومه ومن
بعد ذلك كان المكون العسكري على قلب رجل
واحد حينما نفذ الانقلاب في 25 اكتوبر قبل
اكثر من عام ونصف العام تقريبا
ولكن هذا الانقلاب اصطدم بواقع
لم يتمكن معه الى المضي الى الامام
هبت الثوره
ودموع الجماهير ضد هذا الانقلاب منذ يومه
الاول ومن بعد ذلك ضربت عليه عزه دوليه
واضحه
ترتبت عليها اثار اقتصاديه كبيره جدا
وعزه كبيره تشبه بما اعله النظام السابق
في فترات فكان نعم
طيب اكمل الفكره استاذ يوسف
لذلك انا اعتقد انه بقوه
السياسي ضغوط الكثيفه الواقعه على المكون
العسكري الذي كان مجتمعا على الانقلاب من
بعد ذلك وسط الضغوط الداخليه والخارجيه
اجبر على الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
مجددا وتم ايضا بدفع من المجموعات الدوليه
كما تتابعين هنالك الرباعيات الدوليه التي
تضم الولاده المتحده والمملكه المتحده
والامارات بريطانيا اضافه الى الثلاثيه
ممثله في بعثه الامميه اضافه الى منظمه
الايجاز والاتحاد الافريقي هؤلاء اجبروا
الاطراف الى الجلوس مجددا اذا القوه
السياسيه دفعت فقط بشروطها في هذا الامر
وتحدثت عن انها في هذه المره المرحله لا
تريد شراكه مع مكون عسكري في السياسه بل
ان العمود الفقري للاتفاق الايطالي قائم
على ابعاد الجيش عن المشهد السياسي تماما
وهذا تم التوافق على الحل يعني هناك
العديد من النقاط الشائكه التي سنناقشها
ايضا معك في سياق هذه التغطيه ولكن ساعود
اليك استاذ يوسف سراج الدين مره اخرى
اذا عمليه الاجلاء الامريكيه سبقتها عمليه
اجلاء سعوديه حيث قالت وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه ان مواطني المملكه الذين تم
اجلاؤهم من السودان وصلوا الى البلاد
اضافه الى عدد من رعايه دول اخرى وبينت
الوزاره في بيان لها ان القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه اجلت واحد وتسعين سعوديا
ونحو 66 شخصا من 10 دول اخرى عربيه
واجنبيه واكدت خارجيه ان المملكه عملت على
توفير كامل لاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه
الاجانب تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى
بلدانهم
من جانبه قال نائب وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
قال ان معظم السعوديين الذين طلبوا
الاجلاء من السودان تم اجلاؤهم وخلال
استقباله السعوديين والرعايه الاجانب
العائدين من السودان الى جده اوضح نائب
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه ان هناك تكادفا
بين كافه الاجهزه لتنفيذ عمليه الاجلاء
واكدا ان وزاره الدفاع السعوديه لعبت دورا
كبيرا في تنفيذ الخطه وضاف ان وزاره
الخارجيه لديها توجيهات للعمل على راحه
السعوديين في الخارج تتواجد على متن سفينه
جلاله الملك ابها وهي اخر سفن الخاصه
الاول التي خصصت لعمليات الاجلاء من
السودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده على متنها 37 شخص جنسيات متعدده
بمقدمتها الجنسيه الاماراتيه والقطريه
وكذلك الجنسيه البنغلاديشيه وغيرها من
الجنسيات العربيه وغير العربيه نتحدث عن
37 شخص وهي الدفعه الاخيره من 158 شخص تم
اجلائهم الخرطوم برا الى بورت سودان ومن
ثم بحرا الى مدينه جده وتحديدا في قاعده
الملكه فيصل البحريه هنا في جده نتحدث عن
عمليات جلاء تمت بعمليات بكل يسر وسهوله
من خلال تنسيق عالي بين قطاعات حكوميه عده
وبين السفاره السعوديه وقوات البحريه
السعوديه وكذلك وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
لتحدث عن واحد وتسعين السعودي من ضمن
المائه 158 شخص تم اجلاهم اكثر من 11
جنسيه باعمار مختلفه مخصصه القوات البحريه
خمسه سفن اربعه منها هي خاصه بعمليات
الاجلاء والخامسه كانت هي خاصه بعمليات
التموين جميعها وصلت منذ ساعات مبكره وهذه
هي السفينه الاخيره وهي السفينه جلاله
الملك
ابها وهي السفيره الاخيره الخاصه بعمليه
النقل او وجلاء الرعايه نتحدث انه 158 شخص
وصلوا جميعهم الى مدينه جده وتحديدا في
قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه ونتواجد الان على
متن السفينه الاخيره الخاصه بعم نتحدث انه
وصلت تباعا بينهما ما يقارب الخمسه
واربعين دقيقه عمليه نقل تمت وفق تنظيم
ووفق تنسيقات عاليه بين الحكومه السعوديه
وعدد من الجهات هنالك في الخرطوم للتاكد
من وصول وسلامه كافه الرعايه من السعوديين
وغير السعودي
عمليه تنظيم الاجلاء من الخرطوم كانت تسير
بشكل ممتاز رغم ان الرحله كانت مخيفه بعض
الشيء كنا خائفين جدا مما كان يجري هناك
بسبب المعارك لكن السفاره السعوديه اتت
الينا الى منازلنا لانقاذنا وذهبنا في
موكب الى بورت السودان ثم الى هنا بواسطه
السفن السعوديه لم تكن لدينا خطه للاجلاء
كنا نترقب فقط لكن السفاره السعوديه هي
التي ساعدتنا على المغادره كنت على متن
الخطوط السعوديه او من الناس اللي كنا
ركاب الطياره والحمد لله
طلعنا بسلام
وطيبين وبخير وتم اجلائنا اول شيء وصلنا
للسفاره السعوديه ثم خرجنا من السفاره
السعوديه على اجلاء كان سلس وسهل الحمد
لله ونشكر خدمه الحرمين الشريفين ولي عهد
الامين ووزير الخارجيه وكل القائمين على
هذا الاجلاء الناجح
اشاد وزير الخارجيه الكويتي الشيخ سالم
عبد الله الجابر الصباح بالكفاءه العاليه
للجهات السعوديه التي اسهمت في انجاح
عمليه اجلاء المواطنين السعوديين وعدد من
مواطني دول الاخرى وذلك خلال اتصال هاتفي
مع وزير الخارجيه السعوديه امير فيصل بن
فرحان كما بحث الوزيران الجهود المبذوله
لوقف التصعيد العسكري بين الاطراف
المتنازعه وانهاء العنف وتوفير الحمايه
اللازمه للمدنيين السودانيين والمقيمين
بما يضمن امن واستقرار ورفاه السودان وشعب
هذا واعلنت الكويت عن اجراء كافه
المواطنين العالقين في السودان الذين
رغبوا في العوده من هناك واكدت الخارجيه
الكويتيه في بيان ان المواطنين الكويتيين
وصلوا مدينه جده السعوديه سالمين وجاري
نقلهم الى البلاد اضافت الوزاره انها قامت
بتنفيذ عمليه طارئه الاجلاء المواطنين
الكويتيين العالقين في السودان جراء
للشبكات المسلحه والتطورات الامنيه الحرجه
التي يشهدها السودان
اكد رئيس مجلس سياده الانتقال السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان اكد في تصريحات
العربيه ان كل مطارات السودان تحت سياده
الجيش السوداني باستثناء مطري الخرطوم
ونيالا واتهم البرهان قوات دعم السريع
بتفتيش المنازل ومصادرات الاموال
والاعتداء على البعثات الدبلوماسيه مشيرا
الى نهاد القوات تنتشر في الاحياء السكنيه
والمجمعات الخدميه كل المطارات
الخرطوم في اشكاليه ومطار مياه اشكاليه
بقيه بطارات السودان كلها تحت سيطره
الدوله طبعا رعايه دول اصابهم الفلع
واصابهم الخوف من الممارسات مجموعات الدعم
السريعه داخل الاحياء السكنيه وهي تفتش
المنازل وتصادر الاموال وتعتدي على انتفاخ
الدبلوماسيه دون
اي لحرمه
المواطنين
الان هذه المجموعات منتشره داخل احياء
السكنيه داخل المجمعات القدميه وتقوم
بافعال
اله الخ
وف والان مجموعات كبيره لدعم سريع اخرجت
المواطنين في المنازل اخرج
اخلط المستشفيات واحتلت المستشفيات موجوده
في كثير
قواتهم داخل الخرطوم في مناطق سكنيه وسط
السكان
والصلاحياتنا وتم الهجوم علينا من قبل هذه
المجموعات المتمرده طبعا
نحن نقوم بالدفاع ولا نريد ان نخرج نخرج
الى خارج دائره الدفاع لاننا نظن ان ذلك
يتسبب في اضرار كبيره واضرار بالغه على
السودانيين الان
تشردت مئات قتلوا
البنيه التحتيه تضررت في حرب عبسيه ليست
لديها جدوى سوى اكاذيب الذي يدعيها الطرف
الاخر لانه يحارب الشلول ويحارب الجماعات
الاسلاميه الان ما في اي جماعات اسلاميه
اص
ابه النظاميه واصاب اس الدوله السودانيه
كشف محمد حمدان دقلو قائد قوات الدعم
السريع كشف في تصريحاتنا العربيه انه
متواجد في الخرطوم برفقه مقاتليه حيث يحرص
على توجيههم في المعارك وتتبع تطورات
للشبكات هذا وصرح حميتي بان قواته بصدد
مواجهه مجموعه من المرتزقه المنتمين
لمجموعه الاسلاميه وذلك بعد استسلام عناصر
الجيش السوداني على حد قوله
اسامه عبد الله مجموعه من التركيزات
مجموعه من الاسلام
الان هم الجيش
قاتلونا يعني اجانب الان الاجانب موجودين
داخل العمارات
البرهان هو الايه
حتى لو كتله
الديموقراطيهم بالطريقه الثانيه
معكم في هذه التغطيه ومع ضيوف العربيه
نذهب الان الى القاهره الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني عادل ابراهيم حمد استاذ
عادل اهلا بك معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه
المتابع يوم امس لتصريحات القائدين
وتصريحات الرجلين نتحدث عن تصريحات ناريه
هذه المره يتحدث كل منهما وكانه انا او لا
احد غيري ماذا نشي من هذه التصريحات فيما
يتعلق بالمرحله المقبله في الايام المقبله
الا تصريحات في ظاهرها
تصريحات تتكلم عن
الوضع العسكري
وحرب
بالتحديد على حديث قائد الدعم السريع بانه
يحارب
مرتزقه ويحارب اجانب ويحارب جماعات
اسلاميه
وفي هذه الحاله كانه يعني
يعيد اتهام وموجه لغات الدعم السريع
تاريخيا هي متحبه بانها تضم اجانب
سودانيين وجماعه
متفلتهامات تقليديه نسخت بجماعات الدعم
السريع منذ تكوينها والى الان
فكانه يريد ان نعيد هذا الاتهام ويرده الى
الطرف الاخر باعتبار انه يحارب
متطرفين ويحارب جانب ويحارب مرتزقه ولكن
انا الحقيقه يعني ارجو ان يكون التركيز
نعم هو انعكاسه الانصرار سياسي واصلا هذه
المعركه اندلعت بعد ان انقسم الفريق
الفريقان العسكريان بين مؤيد لاتفاق
الاطار الممثل في القوات الدعم السريعه
التي كانت دائما لهذا الاتفاق والقوات
المسلحه التي كانت متحفظه او تعترض على
هذا الاتفاق لان القوات المسلحه
كانت كانت غير راضيه او رافضه
لطريقه هيكله الجيش باعتبار ان هذا امر
عسكري بحث لا يفترض ان يقود فيه مدنيون او
تقول لهم اغراض في اضعاف الجيش الاتهام
كان موجه
والحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي والذي
استعماله وتدعم السريعي الى جانبه واكثارت
كانها ظهيره عسكري لقوى الحريه والتغيير
التي قدمت الاتفاق الايطالي انفجرت هذه
الاحداث او هذه المعارك
انعكاس لذلك الصراع السياسي وحسب راي
القوات الدعم السريع
تحركت موسانده
للقوى السياسيه
المؤيده او التي هندسه هذا الاتفاق
الاطاري
ولقائى الدعم السريع رؤيه في ان يكون هو
له في المستقبل القريب له دور سياسي وهو
ظهير عسكري للقوه المدنيه التي التي تحكم
وفق هذا الاتفاق في المرحله القادمه على
ان يضعف الجانب الاخر الذي يقوده القوات
المسلحه بقياده الفريق البرهان فانا في
رايي انه هذا الامر كله هو انعكاس لصراع
سياسي وان كان ظاهر الامر هو خلاف بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السري لانه مساله هيكله
الجيش وضم القوات الدعم السريع وامر لا
يتناسب مع قوه هذه المعارك وهذه واشتدادها
وشراسه المعارك موضوع الهيكلة موضوع ولو
كان الخلاف ولكنه لا يتناسب مع ما تبع ذلك
الخلاف من معارك ضاريه
وقد اليه من اثار
يعني في ظاهره عسكري ولكنه في باطنه يتحدث
عن انقسام ما بين القوى السياسيه لحين
توقيع الاتفاق الاطاري لكن اليوم لا يمكن
ان ننكر بانه في انتهاكات اليوم من قوات
الدعم السريع المتهمه اصلا
مقال القياده منذ 2019 وكان اليوم التاريخ
يتكرر في اتخاذ المدنيين كضروع بشريه
وايضا عمليات النهب وسلب التي يشكو منها
المواطنون السودانيون اليوم وايضا
بالفيديوهات التي تعرض على مواقع التواصل
التي ننقلها ايضا على الشاشه العربيه
رغم ان قوات الدعم السريع
في الانتهاكات والتفلتات باعتبار انها اصل
القوات من افراد لم يخضعوا للتدريب
العسكري المتعارف عليه ولم يتخرجوا من
معاهد عسكريه وبالتالي جلود غير معدين
للعمل العسكري وفق ضوابطه واخلاقياته
المتعارضه ولكن ومع ذلك ومع ذلك انا لا
اريد التركيز على هذه
غير مؤهله لكي تمسك زمام الامور في
السودان
حتى حتى في فتره حكم الانقاذ الذي انشا
هذه القوات حتى تكون ظهيرا للجيش في في
مواجهه الحركات المسلحه في دارفور الشهيد
عرفت هذه المواد بانتهاكات لذلك ان حاكم
ولايه شمال كردفان في عهد الرئيس البشير
دخل في مواجهه مع قوات الدعم السريع وتم
طردها من شمال كردفان كان في توتر واضح
بين قوات الدعم السريع
ولايه شمال كردفان حتى قاعد حكومه البشير
فحكومه القوات الدعم السريع لا تفلتات
ولكن لان هذه التلفون كانت بعيده عن
العاصمه
عليها الاعلام كما هو الان عندما حضور
المعارك في داخل عاصمه السودانيه وبالتالي
الصدى الاعلامي لهذه المعارك بيكون اكبر
بكثير ولكن لهذه القوات
تاريخ في التفلت وفي الانتهاكات في دارفور
وفي خارج العاصمه
ومع ذلك انا لا اريد التركيز على هذه
الجانب حتى لا يصرفنا عن جوهر المزارع
المزارع هي صراع سياسي في استعمال فيه احد
الطرفين قوات الدعم السريع في مواجهه
الجيش علل المواجهه العسكريه العسكريه
تساعد على ابطال الانقلاب العسكري
وقع في 50 اكتوبر لم تفلح
المواجهه الجماهيريه في ابطاله وبالتالي
سعه قوه سياسيه للاستعانه بقوه عسكريه
اخرى علها تواجه الانقلاب العسكري وتبطله
التي ايضا سنتحدث عنها ونناقشها في سياق
تغطيه العربيه ولكن انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
من القاهره الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني عادل ابراهيم حمد ونشير ايضا
مشاهدينا الى هذا العاجل وفق وكاله
الانباء لان فرنسا اذا بدات باجلاء
رعاياها من السودان اذا ما زالت عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه وسط
المطالبات الدوليه والعربيه ايضا بعدم
التعرض للمدنيين وايضا الرعايه الاجانب
المتواجدين والبعثات الموجوده في السودان
وايضا في الولايات السودانيه وحتى في
العاصمه يوم امس كانت اعلنت السعوديه عن
اجلاء مواطنيها الموجودين ايضا في السودان
كانت الحديث عن حوالي 91
سعوديا اضافه الى ايضا اجلاء رعايه اجانب
سواء من جنسيات عربيه من الدول الشقيقه
والدول المجاوره وايضا من دول اخرى اذا ما
تحدثنا ايضا عن اجلاء من دول مثل قطر
وايضا الامارات ومصر
وغيرها ايضا من الدول من الدول العربيه
ايضا وغيرها من الجنسيات باكستان الفلبين
وغيرهم كان هناك ايضا اشاده بالدور
السعودي المملكه العربيه السعوديه بهذا
الدور الحاسم في عمليات الاجلاء اليوم
ايضا تمت بنجاح عمليات اجلاء امريكيه ولم
تتعرض ايضا العمليه العسكريه الامريكيه
التي استمرت لحوالي ساعه واحده في السودان
لم تتعرض لاي مشاكل لاجلاء الدبلوماسيين
الامريكيين واليوم اعلنت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بانه لم يتبقى اي شخص واحد من
الدبلوماسيين في السودان الذين بلغ عددهم
وهم اقل من 100 شخص حتى هذه الساعه والان
فرنسا اذا بدات باجلاء رعاياها من السودان
بانتظار المزيد من المعلومات في الساعات
المقبله حول حيثيات الاجلاء الفرنسيه نذهب
الان الى واشنطن الصح فيه السودانيه فاطمه
غزالي اهلا بك استاذه فاطمه معنا كيف
تتابعون حتى هذه الساعه التطورات الاوضاع
في السودان على الصعيد العسكري وايضا
التصريحات السياسيه
شكرا لك
شكرا لقناه العربيه
حقيقه يعني ما يحدث
يعني عمليه الاجلاء
التي تمت
يعني لها طبعا تاثيره على الراي العام
الامريكي
وهذه يعني تعد خطوه يعني وانجاز كبير
للاداره الامريكيه في هذه المرحله
هل تعلمين ان الراي العام الامريكي يعني
يتاثر باي قضيه تتعلق بالمواطن الامريكي
في اي منطقه فيها لساعات او فيها حروب
اجلاء يعني
الدبلوماسيين والرعايه الامريكيين من
السودان في ايضا يعني
قراءات يعني يظهر ان الطرفين ايضا يعني
اتفقا على مساله ان تكون الاوضاع هادئه
جدا
في فتره
الاجلاء وهذا ما تم لذلك يعني تحدث
مسؤولين الاداره الامريكيه عن ان الاجلاء
تم بسلام
حقيقه هذه هذا الاجلاء فيه مخاوف بعض
الناس او يتخوفون من ان هذا الابتلاء
للدبلوماسيين والرعايه الاجانب قد يفتح
الباب يعني يجعل افتح الباب يعني
واسعا
لمزيد من
العنف لمزيد من
الضرب في مناطق يعني ماهوله بالمدنيين هذه
من المخاوف ولكن طبعا من حق هؤلاء الرعايه
والاجانب ايضا ان يعودوا الى بلادهم امنين
سالمين استاذه فاطمه يعني هذا من وجهه نظر
امريكيه فيما يتعلق بالراي العام الامريكي
لقيام اداره بايدن باجلاء وانهاء هذه
العمليه بنجاح اليوم انت تقيمين في واشنطن
كيف تتابع الجاليات السودانيه تطورات
المشهد اليوم في السودان
طبعا يعني الجاليات السودانيه والسودانيون
الامريكان منذ اندلاع هذه الحرب يتابعون
الحرب باستمرار هنالك جهود مبذوله يعني
لدرجه انهم يجمعون تبرعات لعلها تساعد في
مساله يعني مساهمه في التخفيف من حده
الاوضاع الانسانيه السيئه حتى صلاه العيد
يوم امس يعني ذهبنا الى صلاه العيد كانت
صلاه العيد وصلاه القائد كان هنالك حزن
مخيم على
الجاليه السودانيه بواشنطن الكبرى وعدد من
الجاليات هنالك تواصل ومجموعات ضغط تذهب
الى الاداره الامريكيه اليوم كانت هنالك
وقفه امام البيت الابيض يوم 29 ايضا هنالك
وقفه امام البيت الابيض والكونجرس هنالك
ايضا يعني
يعني رسائل ترسل عبر البريد وعبر الهاتف
للممثلي
الكومبرس يعني كله في
منطقته او في
المحليته يرسل رساله للكونجرس او
للممثل في مجلس الشيوخ
للحديث عن ضروره الدوري الامريكي في ايقاف
هذه الحرب هنالك جهود مكثفه كبيره جدا من
السودانيين في امريكا وهذا لم يكن لمجد لم
يكن يعني جديد على المجتمع السوداني
الامريكي ظل على تواصل حتى في الثوره
الثوره ديسمبر كان لديه دور كبير ويعني
تعلمين انه نظم مارش يعني تحدثت عنه يكون
القنوات وتحدث عنه كل العالم ابانا الثوره
وكان دافع عن تشجيعيا للسواب السودانيين
الامريكان يعني يتواصل مع المؤثرين في
الاداره
التنفيذيه وللتشريعيه
اسمحي لي يعني انتهى الوقت وانا اشكرك
جزيل الشكر الحديث حول التحركات السودانيه
من العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن شكرا جزيلا
لك ونشير ايضا الى جريده الاخبار المتعلقه
هذا تقرير للامم المتحده يتحدث عن زياده
عمليات النزوح من جميع مناطق الخرطوم
ومدينه الاوبيض بشمال كردفان وكان ايضا
تحدث التقرير حول جديد المعطيات المتعلقه
بالتقارير لمقتل 132 شخصا في الخرطوم و95
في شمال كردفان و61 بشمال دارفور وايضا
التقرير يشمل العدد الاجمالي حتى هذه
الساعه
لمقتل الاشخاص مقتل 413 شخصا واصابه
3500 اخرين في الاشتباكات في السودان حتى
الحادي والعشرين من ابري اي قبل يومين من
الان وزياده اذن عمليات النزوح من جميع
مناطق الخرطوم والابيض بشمال كردفان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات